mike miner making his
206th career start yeah mike miner go
ahead mike now you take that baton from
those youngsters and don't let them show
you up go ahead and pitch your pitches
with you got some really good ones and
you know he's eating up innings this
year that's one of the reasons why they
got him and having correa to protect him
in the four spot
o'hern
can of corn makes the catch
miner with the shutout first in bottom
of the first inning no score between the
astros and royals on the bump you can
see him right there the big man luis
garcia
22 games 20 of them have been starts
whip is beautiful getting close to that
one mark 134 strikeouts on the season i
don't know you know a good young pitcher
like this should get him in the first
inning get an opportunity to get a run
off him you gotta execute get him home
salvy belts it to center field
backing up is myers he'll make the catch
tagging at third with merrifield and
perez does his job giving the royals a
one-nothing lead rbi number 78. nothing
royals top of the second he has the
astros left fielder today swing and a
miss scott diaz fishing for a slider off
the plate away and that is the first
strikeout for minor one out
swaying and a miss and he strikes out
chaz mccormick back-to-back strikeouts
of diaz and mccormick to open the second
inning now number nine battered jacob
wilson
and that is in there for strike three at
the knees
and wilson goes down looking on the
breaking ball
so minor allows a couple of two out base
runners but that's it he strikes out
three in the inning here's hunter dozier
having a good series against the astros
three for ten with a couple of home runs
as there's a strikeout for luis garcia
picks up his first k of the day that'll
bring up ryan o'hearn swinging a miss
garcia back-to-back strikeouts on three
pitches getting doger and o'hearn the
third inning
the first batter here he moves runners
he can do just about everything there it
is
santana will take it and tag him out
yeah he wanted that to go a little bit
more towards width at second base so he
could pull santana off the base and walk
in tough uh to line that up now back to
guriel who's had a lot of success
against minor
it's sharply backhanded by lopez
[Applause]
skips it over to santana nice pick well
you look at nikki saying thank you
miners 02 is tapped back to
michael one two three go the astros in
the third lopez has really proved to be
a tough out in his last five games he is
seven for 17.
that ball is struck well
deep to right and it is nikki lopez's
first home run of the year
did i say the royals won't beat you
with a long ball
how about
nikki lopez
putting a jolt only major league player
with 350 plus plate appearances and no
home runs you can put it into that one
that's a little hanger great follow
through look at the stiff front leg
that's a power hitter right there
so the astros trying to answer after the
two-run home run by nikki lopez here's
chaz mccormick
on the ground this one stays fair dozier
to second for one mccormick beats the
relay throw astros get a run carlos
correa crosses the plate and it's now a
three to one kansas city lead jake myers
with five hits and ten times up in this
series struck him out
one ball and two strikes two outs
castro swings and grounds it right side
whit backhands and throws from shallow
right in time and the inning is over
luis garcia giving up a two out two run
home run to nikki lopez last inning will
face the four five
and six hitters in this lineup for
kansas city that ball line but on one
big hop jose altuve has it in the shift
hit hard by carlos santana
but the astros haven't played well
there's one away
1-0 pitch popped high in the air to
center field
myers
puts it away for out number two
runner on the go and the throw a little
bit oh in time i think it caught him on
the head how about that castro gets his
first caught stealing of the year looked
like benintendi was in there but a
caught stealing as he is tagged on the
helmet jake wilson leads off inning
number five for houston
it's sharply
lopez from his knees oh he got him got
him what a play oh my goodness
just add another highlight reel
to the long tape already
man oh man but that is really showing
some quick feet
to be able to get to that ball and then
to get to your feet to get something on
the throws outstanding we head to the
sixth inning of play mike miner has a
three to one lead ground ball left side
dozier
throws out alvarez so hopefully they can
do what they did before when he got on
base to string some hits together and
get some big hits and push some runs
across that home plate that ball punched
into right field and that's gonna be
down for a hit correa heading to third
that falls off the wall he'll be waved
around the relay throw will not be made
carlos correa scores on the rbi double
by a led miss diaz
and we have a one-run game as chaz
mccormick has a chance to tie the game
up
there's a ball roped to left field that
will be down for a hit that'll tie the
game up chazzy fizz
picks up an rbi and a head first slide
in the second we're tied at three
so it's a runner at third with one out
for alvarez
jammed him
santana's coming home
and they got him
one of the best plays by santana this
year
but to backhand and throw it off balance
and put it up perfect for gallagher to
nail altuve to go ahead run was a thing
of beauty now with very field bats
swag and a miss at a 98 mile an hour
fastball ryan stanek a big strikeout of
the dangerous whip merryfield but he has
had no problem throughout his career
getting lefties
as he gets nikki lopez here and a little
scream coming off the mound first two
hitters for the astros here in the ninth
ground ball outs that brings up guriel
to right field dyson
that's pretty good work by stomach three
days in a row now hunter dozier who
homered last night
and that one is rolled and by pressly
they still have a moment oh and it gets
away
but that'll bring santana all the way to
third base we'll see if alberto can be
the hero
ground ball towards third diaz has it
makes the throw
in time to get alberto and we're gonna
head to extra innings the astros have
loaded up the bases here in the 10th
there's a line driving to center field
that's down for a base hit into score is
guriel the astros take their first lead
of the game it's in the 10th and it's
now 4-3 so the veteran irvin santana
with that slider faces
chas mccormick low ball four santana
after getting ahead of chaz mccormick oh
and two
walks in a run and the astros now lead
at five to three
apollo's drill to left field is it deep
enough ben and tendy is there he makes
the catch tagging is correa trying to
score he will right before the tag is
made on oled miss diaz to get out of the
10th inning but the astros do get that
run which pushes the lead to three
now gerard dyson bats
line drive left field coming on bradley
and he makes the catch goes down to the
ground but holds on
applause from christian javier as
michael brantley who came on in this
game late as a pinch hitter a fine
playing left now javier trying to get
with mary field
in the air playable jake myers in center
field calls off mccormick and puts it
away and the astros win 6-3 in 10
innings